this is a production of Cornell
University
I thank you Tony for that nice
introduction and thank you again for the
opportunity to come in and talk today as
Tony said this has kind of been
something that's been ruminating at
least for me for longer than I've known
Tony this is actually like a five year
going on longer type of thing so I want
to I don't want to dive into too much
that right now because that's part of my
presentation but just again I want to
thank you for this chance to talk to you
and like Tony said oh really we're
really looking for feedback so even if
you don't have something now today you
think something we'd be happy to hear
from you so I'll go ahead and get
started here and I just want to just
give a little outline of what I'm going
to talk about today so you can kind of
follow me through this and this is for
the presentation I'm going to give a
little background and you know and
before just jumping right into this I
thought it'd be helpful if I told you
how I got to where I am with this and
how we how we got to thinking about this
at least how I did so I'm going to talk
about thought process my thought process
because for those of you who are in
graduate school right now you're having
all kinds of thoughts or maybe you
having no thoughts but at some point if
you stay in this business long enough
you're going to put those thoughts
together and this could be a way to go
to kind of see that process so and I'll
talk about some time points as we go
along then we hit hit the key research
papers that kind of where I found really
underpin this this framework that I'm
going to present to you developing the
framework looking at our conceptual
models testing the models and they're
talking about how that relates to future
directions with this framework and again
when I get to this part this is a really
a collaborative effort between Tony and
another faculty member at Trinity
Western University David Clements and so
those two guys have been helpful in this
process too so first of all the thought
process so thinking broadly broadly
thinking okay that's kind of a
I don't know an oxymoron but you just
kind of ruminate on that and really when
we talk about thought processes there's
one of two ways and I realize I'm
probably maybe categorizing them too
narrowly but in I'm just going to talk
about there's the reduction approach and
that's looking at the idea of reducing
complex interactions and entities to the
sum of their constituent parts in order
to make them easier to study so we break
things down you might work at the
cellular level you might look at one
species that that has a role in
different areas ok that's a reductionist
type of thought process there's also the
reverse of that is the holistic
referring to a big picture mentality in
which a person recognizes the
interconnectedness of various elements
that form larger systems patterns and
objects so now we're going to the big
picture scale where you're looking at
systems and how to different parts work
in these systems so the question is can
you do both and that's something that
I've wrestled with for many years okay
so I'm going to talk about some of the
time points in my career about where I
think my thought process has
crystallized on different areas okay so
I'm going to go back to graduate school
uses University Khalid a California
Davis as Tony mentioned I have a PhD in
soil and biogeochemistry and everyone
has that one course maybe have more than
one course but you have the one course
that really challenges you makes you
think engages you in some way so I had
that one course now there's I had
multiple course but this course was soil
science 105 and this is a field course
in the summer it was three weeks
actually more than three weeks but we
went out all over California and if you
know anything about California it
actually has all 12 soil orders in the
state so we were able to see all 12 of
these on this tour and so you can see
you know whether we are up in the
mountains in the snow whether we were
out in the desert
whether we were in a pit in the forest
areas so here I am you know I don't know
if I'm meditating or taking notes here
is definitely meditated shot but you
know we're on some pretty high elevation
and this group you've really kind of
coalesce as a group and you really start
to exchange ideas thoughts not just you
know during this this kind of field
presentation time and so the motto was
no whining adventure and always move
forward okay so here's why you should
take the class and I think every good
professor has a reason why you should
take the course so here was the
description and they're really what I
highlight is we can never duplicate what
you will see and learn in the field so
there thrust was you need to get out and
experience it okay so did I do it once
no I did it twice because I just
couldn't get enough okay so that's the
first time point that I think I really
was now challenging my thinking okay so
let's move forward to I as Tony
mentioned I did a postdoc at Washington
State University and here's where kind
of the outside the box thinking really
started materialized where I was working
at a center for precision agricultural
and automated systems so completely
different from my graduate school
training this is where engineers get
together and they create these machines
that do all kinds of wild stuff okay so
I thought well how do we apply that to
weeds and weed management well our
traditional approach is the combination
of the various methods and and now that
we have technology and i'm not talking
about biotechnology but technology
sensors automation now we can think
about removing the spatial temporal
constraints and combining the biology
with the technology so i've written a
paper i got a many different authors
together and we wrote a book on this
topic about the future we control and
cropping systems okay so this was
another kind of galvanizing period we're
okay now this is another thought process
so then I went to university Nebraska
assistant professor a lot of energy a
lot of enthusiasm I was really excited
about getting a program going and I
heard about the NSF career program and
that to me was a golden opportunity at
least what I thought to really put
forward an idea and take it to a level
of adding the theory and the things that
I thought were really valuable in look
at and invasive plants the ecology the
evolution and that kind of thing so I
looked into this program i'm sure
everyone knows about it and so i should
also say at that same time I was working
on invasive plants out in the in the
environment and in 2012 Nebraska was in
one of these highlighted colors where
extreme or exceptional drought was
occurring okay so I was thinking about
that I was thinking about invasive
plants the environment okay how are
these things kind of working together
went ahead and submitted a proposal like
an invasive plant species response to
extreme weather events and this is just
a little snapshot the intellectual merit
part of it what were we doing we're
looking at phenotypic characterization
and genetic markers associated with
plant growth and reproduction invasives
versus natives and looking at this hour
star model that was first proposed by
Tillman where the where the the most
competitive species is the one with the
lowest resource requirement and we
wanted to develop greater understanding
of how native and invasive plant species
differ in their adaptation in these new
and existing environments especially
where drought was occurring so really
excited about this i went to to grant
writing workshops talked to the people
said you know is this right am i on
track got a lot of reviews on it k
little roadblock here do not fund all
right everyone said that so there was
nothing fundamentally wrong it was just
you know you got to be exceptional of
the exception of the i should say
outstanding okay so who cares just keep
going with this so
Oh regardless I have looked at a lot of
different proposals this is just a list
which any faculty member i'm sure has
the same list or longer it's interesting
i was talking to a colleague who's now
at administrative level and he said you
know I've still got boxes of proposals
back in the day when you had to actually
write and some and you know send it in
by paper so so this is just showing you
that the thought process hadn't stopped
even though I didn't get funded even
though it was kind of a letdown the
thought process didn't quit okay so here
we are this everyone for those of you
coffee aficionados you know here's the
the percolating coffee pot okay here's
this is my brain a pot of coffee and
it's percolating over the stove with all
these ideas you know I've been exposed
to starting graduate school you know
everything's going and I'm wondering are
we going to get to this nice cup of
coffee well well the jury's still out on
that we haven't I haven't reached that
point but hopefully with what you see
today there's maybe we're getting
towards this point okay so let's go back
to the Alice oh look at let's now move
into the where we're looking at this
framework and looking at what are the
key research papers okay so I'm going to
hit on three papers there's multiple
papers out there on invasion biology but
I'm going to focus on three that I think
really are applicable to what I was
trying to do and now what I've been
working with my colleagues Tony and
David okay so looking at this paper
paper by a Peter Albert at UMass on
invasiveness invasive ility in the role
environmental stress and the spread of
non-native plants okay so what they were
looking at was invasiveness of the
specie versus invasive ility of the
habitat and it's really challenging to
identify traits of invasive plants
because they're different they do
different things in different
environments the habitat type is a
little bit I wouldn't say easier but
more realistic in how to
we quantify it so they're looking at
factors and they identified competition
intensity disturbance regimes
environmental stress and I'm not going
to go into a lot of this but just
highlight the thing that they focused on
was the environmental stress and vase
ability so here's just a little diagram
this is their conceptual model the
difference between these two is this is
cases in which high stress should
decrease in vase ability and this is
where cases of high stress should
increase in vase ability and this is
just conceptual this is what they were
thinking it's not based on empirical
studies so looking at case whoops case
one here we are high stress will kill
the non-native case to the non-natives
are competitively inferior at maximum
stress levels and then case three the
non-natives are slightly competitive at
superior slightly more superior at high
stress levels looking at at the other
other where we have increased in vase
ability case one is non-natives are
competitively inferior at low stress so
where there's low stress and then the
case five non-natives are competitively
superior at all stress levels okay so
we've got that there next I'm going to
jump to this paper by [ __ ] own at all
and they were looking at invasion
success affected by factors okay so
you're hearing this factor term I want
you to remember that because I'm going
to we're going to hit on that again so
looking at their focus was this
migration factor when does something in
invade or when does it first come into
the community and then what happens and
so looking at ecological and
evolutionary changes so they came up
with some invasion scenarios showing how
the factors contributed to invader and
habitat match and here's a diagram from
their paper and I'll just walk you
through this a little bit here is on the
the x-axis here sorry y axis
characteristics of the invaded areas and
of the invasive species
on the x axis we have time and the
invaded area that's this dotted line the
invasive species is the solid line the
migration so when it's introduced is the
arrow and then when the invasion process
starts is the vertical line on the time
axis so they have four scenarios this
first one is only a change in the
migration regime is needed to initiate
invasion so that's pretty simple
invasion begins after change in
innovated area okay so if we look at the
invaded area something's going on and
then at this point the invasion process
actually starts if you flip that around
looking at the invader now there's
something going on here and then at this
point the invasion actually starts and
then finally at the the scenario d where
they had a change in migration and
invaded area needed to initiate the
invasion and so they talk about several
examples about where this occur where
this could occur okay so the last paper
is one by Jessica gurvich at Stony Brook
and she she and her colleagues are
looking at kind of synthesizing where
where we are with biological invasions
so kind of this big picture look at
things and so they came up with this
conceptual synthetic invasion meta
framework real tongue twister but they
defined they just simple simple fight to
sim where the unifying principles of
ecology in evolutionary biology and
really what they were trying to focus on
was the this demography of invasions
where they occur and then looking at
through these three characteristics and
I'm going to touch on this a little bit
because those are kind of fundamental
for our framework where it's looking at
rapid local population increase
monocultures or local dominance and
range expansion and so they looked at
the literature kind of summarized the
different models that were out there and
they came up with their model to help
kind of push us along with quantifying
and testing the
evaluation of these causal factors so
here's a picture cartoon of their figure
where they've shown that the sim can be
applied to this simple case of enemy
escape it's a in this invasion theory
where the invader demography then
relates to this population interactions
and going through this affects these
different invasion components you flip
it around a little bit where it's
applied now to the the example of
ecological and evolutionary components
and this is related to propagule
pressure and here we have basically
looking at human impacts and how they're
related to this process which relates to
invader demography and then again
affecting these two different components
and then finally this is where they
apply it to the the evolution of
increased competitive ability where that
theory is the the invasive plant is
released from its constraints in the new
environment and so they apply their
model to how this might this scenario
might work out and how it would affect
again this rapid population increased
and domination mode and the dominant
monoculture okay so like I said those
are three papers there are several
others and these are just some examples
of really some kind of primary or really
key papers that have been published on
this kind of modeling looking at how do
we understand the theory of invasive
ility whether this paper by Davis
catford at all did a nice study on
looking at invasion ecology and a
theoretical framework I just want to
point out this one by Baniyas really a
nice paper integrating an assessment of
biological invasions so not just plants
but we're looking across the wider
context so these are papers that could
be you know you looked at as well but
now I want to talk a little bit about
what we did as far as develop
our framework so you're kind of getting
used to this paper thing okay so Kohler
and lodge as as a paper that talks about
looking at the the establishment so
invasive plants established in going
through this kind of scenario and it's
important to understand that a lot of
invasive plants they might be introduced
but they don't always establish and so
what these what they did was kind of
describe this in a way of where these
points of failure could be so a species
that's entrained in the transport
pathway whether it's brought over an
ocean whether it's transported across a
region oftentimes there's a failure in
the transport okay if it survives the
transport in and adduction the it failed
to establish maybe the conditions aren't
right maybe it's competitive maybe
there's a disturbance factor that's
limiting that that puffs you know that
that ability when it does establish
sometimes it still remains non-invasive
you can see weeds and vase of plants
that do establish but they're not a
problem they don't reach this final
stage where they're spreading and that's
where they become invasive and I think
I've read a report I the kind of the
ballpark is ten percent of plants
actually become invasive so the ones
that we have that's ten percent of all
the ones that are really that have been
introduced okay so that's this kind of
structure but then for for what we were
looking at again I'm going to go back to
the components that that gurevich had
all talked about because we really
focused on this framework in the context
of these three components so rapid
population increase and this is where
populations increase exponentially so
whether that's at a you know
a single starting from a single plant or
multiple plants there's this rapid
increase and also an established local
dominant so where there's monocultures
that are created with limited or no
diversity and that can occur at again
scales of small local too large but then
we get to range expansion where there's
a dispersal from local populations
occurring in these transition under
servant zones okay so that's kind of
this invasion process now these stages
don't always occur chronologically they
might occur simultaneously but typically
that's the process so that's the best of
those the stages that are that are
included okay so next the goal that we
had was really we're not trying to
predict how and where invasions will
occur which a lot of models do but
instead we're using these three main
factors of resident community the
invader fitness and whether to guide and
develop our understanding of why
invasions occur so these three main
factors on this that we've kind of
included on our framework is the
resident community so what are some
things that are part of the resident
clean obviously there's other plants
there are the micro and macro fauna
there's nutrient soil type there's a lot
of different parts of the resident
community that are factoring into the
invasion process and and again this is
probably simplified to some degree but
it's a starting point of where we're
going invader fitness so how does the
invasive species respond what is the
what are the things such as the
plasticity of the plant you know whether
it's able to adapt what is the genetic
selection of the plants that are there
how are they fit to adapt to those the
new environment or the new habitats
there that they're introduced to and
then finally the weather factor that has
been really important especially
as we see these new extreme conditions
occur but not just extreme highs and
lows also the normal conditions 30 year
averages not just averages but frequency
and duration how frequent are these
events occurring what is the duration
and of course the effects of different
in this case a co2 concentration but
even other gases other other
weather-related factors okay so we've
got factors we've got this kind of
invasion framework where we've got these
components the factors are contributing
to the components so now what we were
going to do now what we did was we went
to the literature and look for empirical
research that would help us to build our
conceptual model to show exactly how
resident community invader fitness and
weather influence the invasion process
ok so we identified three invasive plant
species and we chose these based on
their known kind of well known where
they've been where they're distributed
across the regions or across the country
at least as far as in this country and
then we looked at the number of
published empirical studies for each of
the factors and so these are the number
of papers that were identified again
these are empirical studies with data
that we could use to evaluate as far as
their contribution to these different
factors and ultimately to this invasion
and factor framework so we chose yellow
starthistle non-native common read
muscle I actually also have worked with
these plant species so there's there's a
little bit of a bias there but the point
is we've identified these species and
what we hope to do when we get done is
you could substitute any invasive plant
species and run that through this model
to see what the what the outcome is okay
so just an example this is just a the
top line of
of one of the tables and this is for
yellow starthistle so here's the
reference paper by brown and rice in
2010 and here are the resident community
factor the the four things that we've
kind of grouped these into as far as did
this paper address one of these
subcategories in the factors and we also
looked for if there were other things
related to resident plant community in
this in addition to these other four and
then what we did was assess what was the
invasion component that was affected so
there was three components and we tried
to quantify was it most affecting the
rapid population increase local
dominance or range expansion so for this
paper we were able to assess it as rapid
population increase okay so looking at
Phragmites same thing resident community
oh and i should also note the remaining
papers were categorized into this table
as well as the two others invader
fitness and weather so we had a total of
nine tables that we categorize the
papers i'm not going to show you those
all those tables right now because it
would put you to sleep and I want to
just get through this a little bit
quicker so here's a paper by song at all
again these were the summarizing what
were the things that they looked at
under these different categories and
then here is where we assess what was
the invasion component affected and then
finally for muscle actually a lot of
work has been done on muscle by a person
at Penn State really done a nice job of
looking at all the different factors of
muscle this is an example of some of her
work with a graduate student looking at
simulated grazing then they also look at
pasture grasses in old fields and how
there was competition and we assessed
that is establishing local dominance
okay so looking at our tables we then
took this in
information from the invasion component
that was affected and we used it in this
conceptual model okay so I so so now
we're going to go to looking at how
we're testing this conceptual model and
we wanted to summarize the empirical
studies on our three example invasive
plant species to contextualize our
invasion factor framework so we're using
these what was the invasion component
affected from the category and and
putting it into this model so here's our
figure and this is again this is looking
at the influence of the component in
limiting the invasion success so here's
just one this is the weather factor and
here's for our different our three
species muscle Phragmites and yellow
starthistle and then along the x axis we
have rap rapid population increase
increased local dominance rapid range
expansion and that's from our framework
so these are the components of invasion
success and from what we can see this is
very kind of generalized but looking at
our example invasive species extreme
weather in this case limits invasions
success primarily by affecting the rapid
range expansion components so out here
we see that the that this this was most
limiting to these three species now we
can say different things about this
established local dominance and rapid
population increase because obviously
you know these they're not all at the
same level and and star thistle was
affected across all the different
components of the invasion process but
what's really interesting is the current
predictive models would suggest
otherwise so what we've seen what we
summarized empirically from empirical
studies doesn't necessarily match up
what's with what's being predicted and I
think that's one of the interesting
things that we found out with this and
that's for this weather factor but like
I said I'm not going to go through all
the different figures right now I just
want to kind of bring this back and show
where we're at with this by looking
that these recent conceptual models
broadly synthesized concepts and theory
to test hypotheses improve understanding
and identify research directions so
that's kind of the big picture well the
reductionist approach has focused on
things like fluctuating resource
availability invader and resident
community introduce native ranges and
then these current future climate
conditions so our invasion factor
framework combines the factors affecting
the invasion process and synthesizes it
into a framework so we're trying to
bring both of these together to better
understand for a particular invasive
species why that's been occurring ok so
I'm going to jump really quickly in here
to future directions and talking about
so I've thought back to my thought
process that I kind of introduced
earlier so how would this guide research
you know if I was to be focused on
research what would what would this do
for a research program well if a person
was looking at individual invasive plant
species are there enough empirical
studies on the factor to be able to make
an assessment of it and and in for some
species may be there are adequate number
of empirical studies maybe it's just
been studied to death but the lack of
synthesis maybe it's not been
synthesized to say this is where this
weakness is or this is where it's been a
real critical area that we have now been
able to understand with with the
research is available also an approach
for targeting specific management if you
know something specific maybe it's a
resident plant community effect maybe
it's an invader Fitness maybe it's
something to do with whether can you
target management to really address that
area and then also the thing that's
really fun is to address invasion
theories and really push that to see you
know where are we going to go with with
this thought process so as I kind of
alluded to this model congruence where
we've got this empirically based
conceptual models
and then we've got data driven
projection models and Bethenny Bradley
at University of Massachusetts has done
a lot of work on kind of predicting
different scenarios different situations
with invasive plants but can we bring
these two together with either companion
studies verification tools some way to
say the the projection is actually
reflecting what the empirical research
is showing and that's where I want to
end with this the in son this is a quote
from her paper their paper in 2009 the
uncertainties associated with changes in
climate vegetation communities and the
response of invasive plant species
warrant an urgent need for integrating
modeling and experimental work to better
address the ecological ramifications so
I think that really in a way summarizes
at least for this weather factor now
we've got a lot of other things that you
know we can say maybe similar things but
you know can we bring those two together
to really move this along so with that
I'd like to thank my co-authors again
Tony detomaso and David Clements
department of biology at Trinity Western
University and if there's any questions
thoughts comments I think we have some
time for it so yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu